buenas tardes a todos detrás del casco
no existe género porque creen que este
que digo esta frase
bueno realmente es esta frase porque una
vez que nosotros los pilotos nos ponemos
el casco no importa si eres hombre o
mujer no importa si eres rico o pobre si
eres extranjero o eres de puebla lo
importante es seguir el objetivo y
alcanzar lo que es quedar en primer
lugar en la carrera pues bueno como bien
les mencionaron yo soy piloto
profesional de autos de carreras y
tractocamiones tengo 21 años de edad
tengo 21 años de edad soy orgullosamente
poblana también estudió la carrera de
ingeniería industrial en quinto semestre
y pues llevo nueve años dedicándome a
esta increíble deporte que al principio
comenzó como un hobby como una diversión
como como un sueño como todo el mundo
decía bueno yo cuando sea grande quiero
ser bombero yo cuando sea grande quiero
ser astronauta yo cuando sea grande
quiero ser piloto y pues bueno ahora
este sueño se ha convertido parte de mi
vida es algo que pues como ya mencioné
llevo nueve años haciéndolo y ha sido
algo espectacular
y comencé a los 56 años viendo las
carreras de autos
en la televisión siempre me encantaba me
gustaba mucho pues esa adrenalina de que
los coches fueron ahí tocando se fueran
peleando los primeros lugares e incluso
muchas veces aquí en el autódromo de
puebla mi papá me llevaba a ver las
carreras y me fascinaba me encanta el
olor a la gasolina la llanta quemada
pero lo que más me causaba con un
poquito de
de duda era porque no había mujeres eran
puros hombres musculosa y todos bien
guapos con sus mega cascos y todo no sea
porque no hay mujeres y pues fue algo
que la verdad nunca nadie me supo
responder pero en una de esas carreras
le dije oye pa a mí me gustaría ser
piloto y mi papá sí claro un sueño de
cualquier niño no que no para de verdad
es algo que a mí me gustaría hacer me
gustaría estar ahí peleando entre esos
hombres y estar destacando como mujer en
ese ámbito de un deporte totalmente
considerado de hombre entonces pues mi
papá me dijo bueno si realmente lo que
quieres cuenta con mi apoyo vamos a
empezar de menos a más y empecé en estos
que pueden ver mi regalo de navidad mi
primer regalo de navidad en lugar de
muñecas eran coches y yo era la más
feliz era la más realizada empecé en los
bocartes que es unos karts muy pequeños
que yo creo que pues la mayoría de aquí
pueden ubicarlos y también lo combino un
poquito con las motos pocket bike que
son las motos pequeñas
y pues bueno comenzó todo como un sueño
como un hobby como una diversión y algo
a mis 12 años me invitan a una
convocatoria de 125 pilotos a nivel
nacional jóvenes de 12 a 15 años y pues
bueno yo fui a la convocatoria yo dije
ah perfecto yo no soy toda una experta y
cuando llego decepción total porque yo
veo a otros pilotos de todo méxico con
sus cascos así super mega pintados sus
overoles llenos de mar gastos así
profesionales y yo de verdad no tenían
nada os ayuda apenas pues estaba
conociendo este ámbito del deporte pero
realmente no tenía el conocimiento total
de que era algo profesional y bueno
después de toda esta larga convocatoria
al mes me llega la mejor noticia de mi
vida de sus 125 pilotos hombres buenos
124 conmigo la única mujer 125 me llega
la noticia de que bajó bienvenida eres
la única mujer y representarán a puebla
bueno me puse a llorar una emoción
increíble ni dónde estaba conmigo se
puso a llorar también pero ya no de
emoción ya de miedo porque porque su
hija la bonita la chiquita
y va a estar en un deporte arriesgando
su vida y va a estar en un deporte de
puros hombres tratando de pelear y
tratando de este carro entonces para mi
mamá fue una noticia muy difícil mi papá
también fue súper felices y mi hija
quedó yeah mi papá mi mamá sí fue una
noticia muy impactante pero a pesar de
eso decidió apoyarme dijo ok pues a lo
mejor va a ser algo pasajero ya cuando
empiece con los novios el antro y así lo
va a dejar no obviamente pues va a estar
más con la sociedad y empezó a pasar el
tiempo y después de un largo tiempo me
demostré a mí misma y a mi mamá pues que
realmente era algo que quería para toda
mi vida entonces después de los karts de
esta convocatoria salté a los autos tipo
turismo
me gustaría contarles la anécdota de
estos autos tipo turismo mi papá una vez
lo invitaron a correr mi papá también
pues estaba muy relacionado con el
ámbito del deporte motor y lo invitan a
correr a un coche de carreras justamente
al que pueden ver del lado izquierdo y
de repente su coequipero le dice oye
sabes que no voy a poder llegar mi papá
como crees como les voy a hacer todo
pues que corra tu hija
como siga pues apenas viene de los karts
no entonces me dice oye pues te gustaría
yo sí claro que sí el asiento no se
corre entonces me hicieron los colchones
de este vuelo para que alcanzara a ver
para que pudiera alcanzar a y el volante
los pedales y bueno al final pude y lo
mejor de todo quedamos en primer lugar
esa carrera una emoción padrísimo eso sí
cada vuelta iba viendo en la zona de
meta en donde están los bandereros
porque me habían dicho bajos si ves una
bandera negra te sales porque estás
poniendo en riesgo tu vida y a la de los
otros pilotos acometiendo estarás muy
mal no entonces cada vuelta pues yo
pasaba la meta y ya no hay bandera negra
perfecto sigo no de bandera negra así
todo el agua toda la carrera hasta que
pues al final yo ni sabía en qué lugar
iba con estás veces no habían rebasado
todo todo pero finalmente pues quedamos
la carrera en primer lugar y fue algo
padrísimo que o sea es una sensación
combinada de muchísimos sentimientos y
algo que pues realmente pues como que te
sientes realizado no sé a qué dices 'wow
que padre que después de todo el
esfuerzo de todo este camino de todos
los comentarios negativos de la gente y
esto pues puedo
puede conseguir mi mi primer objetivo
que era ganar la carrera
en otras categorías que he corrido en la
actualidad estoy corriendo los
tractocamiones que son unos trailers
literal como los que vemos en la calle
repartiendo refrescos o utilería pesada
esos pero convertidos a las carreras y
son la única mujer corriendo estos
tractocamiones tiran agua y son de tu
edad todos los demás pilotos no en
realidad son pilotos varían mucho las
edades hay pilotos de 30 40 50 y 60 años
entonces pues yo soy la única mujer y la
más chiquita en esta categoría y pues es
algo muy padre porque pues existen mil y
un comentarios como los que les he
mencionado haciendo pues obviamente no
vas a poder porque pues eres mujer no
obviamente no porque eres delgadita
porque no tienes fuerza y pues los
resultados han hablado por sí solos
he tenido pues tres obstáculos muy
difíciles muy difíciles durante estos
nueve años uno ha sido esto que les
vengo comentando el ser mujer en un
deporte o ambiente considerado
totalmente de hombres entonces el de
aips tenía que ser vieja ya saben así
entonces pues todos esos en la pista de
repente la mala onda de que está bien
está en el coche y te chocan porque el
simple hecho de la envidia de que una
mujer
ser mejor que un hombre entonces eso ha
sido un obstáculo muy fuerte para mí la
otro ha sido la parte económica es un
deporte muy muy muy caro en el cual pues
yo vengo de una familia muy humilde
entonces pues obviamente no mi papá no
me podía apoyar pues económicamente yo
te pago las llantas la gasolina el coche
el techo que todo no entonces pues tengo
que buscar patrocinadores empresas gente
que crea en mí que quiere apoyarme y
pues también cuando llegó hoy es sabes
que mira te presento mi plan de trabajo
yo me dedico a correr a autos tal tal
tal com sabes que no oye pero por qué no
mira es es muy padre es un deporte no
tan conocido te puede servir no sabes
que no porque una mujer no no le va a
poder ganar nunca un hombre entonces yo
me enojaba me o sea me llenaba de tanto
coraje que pues ni modo no decía bueno
ok les voy a demostrar que sí y así iba
con mil y un patrocinadores que se me re
cerraban las puertas por el simple hecho
de no porque no conozco el automovilismo
no sé qué es y en la otra por no porque
eres mujer y nunca vas a poder ser tan
exitoso como un hombre entonces
pues bueno esto fue algo que a mí les
digo me llenó mucho de coraje dije por
qué no porque dicen que no les voy a
demostrar que sí entonces en cada
carrera por la chava cada vez más ganas
demostraba que si se podía y los
resultados han hablado por sí solos
afortunadamente cuento ya con varios
patrocinadores y pues déjenme decirles
como los convencí los les dije bien
venganza una carrera los invito a que se
suban conmigo los no subí a mi auto le
daba unas cinco vueltas y todos bien
asustado ya ya de patrocino está bien
está bien está bien te mato si es cierto
no pero si los llevaba a las carreras y
pues no sabían realmente que era una
parrilla llenos de hombres y que pues yo
estaba ahí con mi casquito así bien
chiquita pues está bien feliz y todo
siempre con una sonrisa a pesar de todo
y pues ahí le daba y pues tenía buenos
resultados entonces pues ya me decían
oye majo pues la verdad me equivoqué me
estaba guiando por los estereotipos por
todas estos paradigmas que existen que
muchas veces hasta nosotros mismos nos
los creemos no osa sabes que el hombre
no puede bailar ballet la mujer no puede
manejar un tractocamión el hombre no
puede cortar cabello o sant mil mil
cosas que no las vamos creyendo entonces
por eso nos cerramos nosotros mismos las
puertas y por los patrocinadores así se
han ido acercando
y algo buenísimo otra parte y la más
difícil que yo creo que es juego con mi
vida prácticamente estoy a la línea de
la muerte pues he tenido dos accidentes
muy fuertes aquí pueden ver las imágenes
este es el más fuerte que he tenido este
fue el año pasado en san luís potosí en
el óvalo una camioneta como la mía se
quedó pues parada y veníamos saliendo de
una curva de otras cinco camionetas a mí
me taparon la visión por completo y de
repente veo una camarita parada la trató
de esquivar osado y el volantazo y pues
ya no ya no pudo más para reaccionar no
usa formas que dice así frene y de todo
pues punto me están pe a más de 180
kilómetros por hora a 0 así quedó mi
coche fue pérdida total afortunadamente
a mí no me pasó nada me lastimó un poco
la rodilla esté casi me operan pero por
el ejercicio la preparación pues pude
salir adelante pero en ese momento pasó
por mi mente muchísimas cosas muchísimas
cosas créanme que me empecé a creer todo
eso de la gente de ussía a lo mejor y
este deporte no es para mí a lo mejor y
tíos así que estoy arriesgando mi vida
pero
mejor este golpe lo pudo aguantar más un
hombre con una mujer usando empiece a
cuestionar tantas cosas que yo dije no
pues yo creo que hasta aquí va a quedar
mi trayectoria mucha gente pensó que hay
memoria este pero puestos demostré y yo
creo que más que nada a mí mismo que las
barreras son mentales todo esto que pues
la gente dice no las vamos creyendo y
nosotros mismos tanto no las creemos que
lo cumplimos sin querer queriendo lo
hacemos lo cumplimos entonces después de
pues un mes de rehabilitación de estar
pensando todas estas cosas regresé
regresé más fuerte dije no le voy a
tener miedo a algo que he luchado pues
durante ocho años de mi vida por algo
que he luchado que he querido siempre no
lo voy a dejar por un accidente que duda
lo mejor y si me lastimé físicamente un
poco pero pues más que nada por el hecho
o por el orgullo de decir yo quiero
continuar con mi sueño porque siempre he
soñado con esto y lo quiero lograr
entonces pues bueno ha sido complicado
estos estos pasos que he tenido pero
también vienen cosas buenas durante mi
trayectoria como piloto no como ser la
primera mujer más joven en obtener la
licencia de la federación
ser campeona de las 24 horas de méxico
que es una carrera literal de 24 horas
estar en la pista entre otros pues
buenos resultados que he tenido entonces
siempre he dicho que después de algo
malo siempre viene algo bueno y pues yo
creo que eso es lo más satisfactorio
para mí no vamos a tener como buenos
resultados también dentro de mi ámbito
como aquí pueden ver un poco de cifras
en 986 pilotos hombres a nivel nacional
y sólo 10 mujeres entonces pues por eso
le quise poner primero como mis mis
resultados lo bueno que tenía porque
realmente pues a lo mejor si son un poco
presumido de mi parte pero para mí es
todo un orgullo poder estar en este
deporte en el cual mucha gente cree que
es imposible para las mujeres y de 10
mejores que estamos yo creo que soy de
las mejores porque soy poblana entonces
pues voy por buen camino todavía hay una
gran transferencia
todavía hay una gran trayectoria que
recorrer y pues entonces pues de estas
mujeres representativas en el ámbito del
deporte motor es increíble y pues bueno
como alcanzar tus sueños algo que me ha
servido mucho a mí es ser perseverante
por más que pasen estos obstáculos
seguir adelante tener claros los
objetivos y la meta a dónde queremos
llegar cómo lo queremos lograr creer en
ti mismo es algo que a mí me ha servido
mucho por lo mismo que hay tantas cosas
a nuestro alrededor
creen en ti mismo es la mejor fuente y
obviamente el pensamiento en positivo
prepararte físicamente y mental bueno en
mi caso es más es combinar de las dos
pero yo considero que la mental es lo
más fuerte o sea lo más necesario y
analizar los errores para pues
mejorarlos
bueno y otra parte comentó
bueno si me pueden ayudar y también hay
cosas que no me han servido durante mi
trayectoria para cumplir mi meta es
hacerle caso a los comentarios negativos
de la gente creerme los por qué pues les
digo que eso es lo que muchas veces nos
cuestionamos tantas cosas que no lo
vamos creyendo confiarme de las cosas
igualmente no darle importancia a los
pequeños detalles que van sucediendo
nuestras vidas debemos adhesivos este se
ponchó una llanta así pues me raspé así
pues os dije una grosería pues esos
pequeños detalles cada vez se van se van
haciendo más es que al final para
cumplir nuestra meta cuesta muchísimo
trabajo entonces pues darle importancia
mejor a estos detalles para mejorarlos y
pues no dudar de tus capacidades y no
tener miedo a intentar por fracasar
siempre avienten se usar por más
riesgoso que sea si de verdad sueñan y
anhelan con eso avienten se pues les
digo yo tenía miedo de volver a chocar
de volver a lastimarme me aventé porque
es algo que yo quiero que sueño con
ellos y que quiero llegar a ser exitosa
como todo como comenzar mi plática todos
tenemos sueños y metas en la vida a mí
me gustaría
pues bueno correr y correr fuera de
mexico ya sea en estados unidos o en
europa
me gustaría representar a méxico y al
pueblo obviamente también ser la primera
mujer mexicana y poblana en llegar a
estas categorías que muchas mujeres lo
han intentado y han fracasado y ya no lo
vuelven a intentar por ese miedo de
volver a fracasar el fracaso no es malo
eso es un obstáculo una barrera mental
pero intentarlo es lo bueno y pues bueno
dirán porque la foto del medio porque
por eso estoy aquí para dar lo mejor
dicen bueno y la piloto está que no
realmente pues bueno no es para venir
les a presumir sino para aconsejarles
con mi trayectoria de vida con mi
experiencia de vida pues que luchen por
sus sueños que no se den nunca por
vencidos y que crean en uno mismo yo
creo que es lo más importante entonces
pues no se olviden de todas estas
pequeñas pláticas que pues les vamos
nosotros aquí comentando con ustedes
compartiendo porque realmente yo creo
que nos sirve mucho la vida y abrirnos a
escuchar y pues luchen por sus sueños
siempre dicho que no hay edad para
y seguir los sueños no importa si el
chiquito si eres grande si tienes 50 60
si ya te vas a morir siempre hay un
sueño en la vida entonces hay que
proponerse metas en la vida objetivos
para cumplir nuestros sueños y no sé si
recuerdo la frase con la que empecé
detrás del casco no existe género y
detrás de sus sueños tampoco hay género
muchas gracias
gracias
[Música]